in this video i want to talk about how
to close a higher percentage of deals
and how to close more deals overall
and it's all sent around a single
concept which is the belief continuum
all right and so if you think about this
visual that i have right here so you've
got your salesman here and you've got
your prospect here
right and you see this bubble that i put
over head the prospect has no bubble
inside it's completely empty and they
might have a negative bubble as well
and then you've got the salesman who's
got his belief bubble so many people
like to think like do you believe in
what you
are selling right they ask the question
as though it's a binary answer yes or no
i believe or i don't believe
but it would be much more accurate to
say to what extent do you believe in
right because belief is not a binary
question it is a continuum it is
how much do you believe in what you are
selling because if you thoroughly 100
believe with all of your heart and mind
that what you are selling is true i
guarantee you
that you will sell significantly more
and so what i want to show you is these
two equations
that i wrote down as simple equations
for how to actually sell
many people focus i would say a
disproportionate amount of people focus
on the skill of selling and there
absolutely is a skill to sales you have
to know exactly what to say you have to
know how to say it
but you can shortcut that path to
success
by having conviction and the way that
you have conviction
is by a dramatically understanding
the needs of your prospects so that when
you are talking to somebody
you know exactly what their problem is
so that if your product
perfectly matches their problem you can
have conviction in order to sell it
most salespeople don't even listen to
the prospect at all and simply want to
deliver their pitch
which inherently means that they can't
believe in the product that much because
they're not even thinking about whether
it solves the problem
for the prospect because you can't be
convicted that it's going to solve the
problem if you don't even know what the
problem is
and so they haven't taken any time to
understand the prospect most sales
training
is currently focused on educating
salesmen around the product
when it should be most time focused on
educating the salesmen around the
prospect
and their problems not the product
all right key understanding shift that
has to happen when you're educating a
sales team
and or yourself especially if you're
entering a market that you are not the
avatar
right one of the reasons that many
successful businesses happen from
somebody who
suffered from a pain and then went to go
solve it for themselves and then ended
up solving it for
other people is because they desperately
and they so
clearly understand the thoughts needs
and pains of the prospect
and they know how the product solves
those problems the first
equation here is for increasing closing
percentage and so if it's you that's
selling or if it's a sales team that's
selling
it's the skill of sales multiplied by
the extent to which you believe it is
not yes i believe no i believe
this number can be a hundred right
and the thing is is that i believe that
this number of conviction can grow far
higher
than what skill can give you you can be
a very skilled salesman but let's say
the skill of sales is one to ten
right i'll put this on here so who can
see it let's say your skills tails can
be one to ten
i believe that your skill your your
beliefs around conviction can be one to
a hundred
right so even if your skill of sales is
a two you could have a hundred belief
and i guarantee you that you will close
because people can sense whether you
believe what you are telling them is
true
and they believe that what you are
selling them is going to solve their
problem
right and so most people most sales
teams most sales managers do not focus
enough
on this bubble which is conviction which
is this part of the equation
right if you think about what sales is
it's fundamentally a transference of
belief
and so how can you how can you transfer
an empty cup
how can you transfer a cup that is only
one third full
into another empty cup and expect it to
be over the threshold
of the amount of belief that's required
for a prospect to make a purchasing
decision
of course not right and so we still try
and get the person to say a certain
thing or
pause in this way or have this tonality
or this emphasis and that is important
right and there's definitely a place for
that you have to have the basis of sales
in place
but a much much bigger lever that is
often and most underutilized or
unutilized at all
is the conviction or the extent to which
the salesman believes in what they are
selling
and to what extent it can help solve the
prospects
problems all right and so that will
influence the closing percentage of an
individual or team
the second piece is going to be the work
ethic right so a lot of people have
probably seen really good closers versus
really
bad closers based on their closing
percentage but also total number of
deals closed
personally when you have somebody who
has really high work ethic
then they can make up for a lower
closing percentage by having more
activity
so that means that they are following up
with their pipeline faster they are
following up more times
right they are reaching out to people on
their own in their own time to give
themselves more opportunities
and they can compensate for a lower
closing percentage by simply having more
at bats
right and so if you think about the
expert salesman as having these two
things together which is
you want to have a high closing
percentage and you want to have lots of
units sold
all right and so there's three variables
here you've got skill you've got
conviction and you've got work ethic
but conviction counts twice because if
you believe that what you are selling is
genuinely going to help people you will
follow up faster you will fall
more religiously you will follow up as
though you were trying to help someone
and so let me let me ask you this
question as a is a good mental thought
process
if you could go back in time let's say
you could go back in time five years and
you could talk to yourself
and say hey i want you to put a hundred
percent of the money that we have
right now mind you you couldn't tell the
person that is you your past self that
you are
you in the future right so you you can't
say anything like that but in this
thought experiment
and you went back in time and you said
hey we've got this money in the bank
account i want you to put 100 of money
into this thing called bitcoin or hey i
want you to put 100 money into something
called amazon i want you put
all that money into tesla or whatever
right something that blew up over the
last five years
all right if you were to tell yourself
that let's say
you were talking to you and you were
like um
i'm good thanks right how many times
would you follow up with yourself to get
yourself
to do that thing or do that action or
make that investment
a lot and it's because you truly believe
that it would solve your prospects
problem and you have pure conviction
that what you are selling them
the investment the opportunity that
whatever it is is 100
going to work think about how you would
approach that
how many times would you follow up how
how convicted would you be when you
spoke
would you even be focused on the skill
of selling or would you be focusing on
how true what you say
is and if you can make that perspective
shift and if you're a sales manager and
you're trying to manage a sales team
i would implore you to focus way more of
your time around the thing that counts
twice in the equation
of selling and creating great sales
people which is the belief to which the
extent
the extent to which they believe what
they are selling and to whom they are
selling
then boring with the with the uh the
monotony of the skill which
which don't get me wrong it is very
important to sell there's lots of videos
that you've probably heard where i talk
about the skill of sales
but i think when you when you rate this
and you were in
a forced multiplication standpoint i
don't think that they are equated i
don't think they are equivalent
right and the the proof that i have in
this is that if you look at every single
religious
you know movement you are selling
something very hard to sell which is a
completely new frame of view around the
world
the people who believe this many times
they don't train them in the skill of
selling
they just get them to believe
wholeheartedly in what they are selling
right and so if your salesman and your
sales team are not drinking the kool-aid
quite literally of the products that you
sell or the services that you sell
then that is your problem not whether or
not they are clarifying the problem the
beginning now they should because they
should be listing and they should
believe they want to should make sure
that the
the prospect is is going to be best
served by this right
but big picture if you fix this
everything else will happen
and i'll tell you this is the one last
story around this if you believed
wholeheartedly in the the solution that
you are selling
would you not then spend lots of time
honing your skill probably because you
would want to help more people because
you believe
in the thing that you were selling them
right you would you not if you believe
in this thing wholeheartedly
follow up with as many people as
possible be quick to respond because you
know how much it's going to change their
life
probably and so i think that just like
simon sinek says start with why
i believe that the skill of sales is
fundamentally a transference of belief
and we do need to start with why for
salespeople because it is not
a question of whether or not they
believe it is an ext it is the question
of
to what extent do they believe and if
you can get that to 100 you will never
have problems selling ever again
so hope you found this valuable click
subscribe lots of love and i'll see in
the next video